comment on fait pour les éviter c'est un
peu ça le problème ça se cache dans les
herbes dans les bois c'est tout petit
c'est pas comme si c'était hyper facile
de les repérer le seul truc que vous
pouvez faire c'est de vous couvrir les
bras et les jambes avec des vêtements
longs vous pouvez aussi mettre du
répulsif mais renseignez-vous avant
auprès de votre pharmacien parce qu'il y
en a qui sont des conseillers aux
enfants ou aux femmes enceintes par
exemple et si c'est trop tard on fait
quoi parce que une tique c'est pas un
pitbull quand elle mord on s'en rend pas
compte la première chose à faire quand
vous revenez d'une grande balade dans la
nature c'est de vous inspecter la peau
ce qui est bien partout surtout dans les
plis les aisselles les coudes les genoux
les organes génitaux le CIF le sillon en
terre fessier et si vous avez un doute
bah allez demander à votre formation et
tant que vous êtes à la pharmacie
profitez-en pour acheter un tire TIC
c'est une sorte de petit pied de biche
en plastique qui a été spécialement
conçu pour retirer les squatteuses pour
bien faire il faut glisser l'objet
autour de la tique au ras de la peau un
perpendiculaire et tirer sans bourriner
mais quand même un petit peu fermement
et en faisant un léger mouvement de
rotation